With the first pick in the 2010 NBA draft the Washington Wizards select John Wall
from the University of Kentucky
DeMarcus Cousins
What a tremendous moment for any young player
Patrick Patterson
Yeah, he's being taken on his potential
Eric Bledsoe
Get used to Kentucky players being drafted
Daniel Orton from the University of Kentucky
They come here on a mission. They know why they're here
I'm not here to play college basketball and there be a rec player. I want to be professional
I want to be an NBA player
They're not embarrassed to say it
And I don't want them to be but that started with that moment on that draft night
That was like what just happened
What I remember from the recruiting process
Huh, he came in and just talked, he didn't talk about basketball, he talked about life in general
What does he see me as a person, what I can be
And my mom said I trust that man, I can trust you going that far with him
When my mom gave me the word, that was it
I wasn't really looking for coaches just telling what I wanted to hear you work hard
You're gonna get what you want, and I'm gonna help you get there
you know, me and John
Communicated a lot you know when he switched to Kentucky then you know Eric came into the picture
When I went in to see him his high school coach said
Why would he go there if you're taking John Wall? I said well if your best two players are at the same position, what do you do?
He said I play them. Well that's what I do
No, [we] wants to get old Cabin just good job
You could just kind of tell the circus hadn't been in town since patina and the circus [was] back
Bill locks
Kentucky became the it program overnight, and I think it was big blue Madness. It didn't the John wall dance
Launch the year. I didn't know he's Gonna
Go worldwide [nearby] don't make a big deal out of it
But I think we just brought a carrot sense of fun and excitement to the state of, Kentucky
Best one there was a lot of sizzle and a lot of pop to that team and John wall
I really think personified that he gave that team its swagger like roll out the ball
And you can look around and you can see him on your side. You say you know what whatever else happens tonight
We got the best player in this game, so I kind of like my chances
They played North Carolina again the team that was taking all our recruits
Wall goes coast to coast on a play where he essentially runs through the whole team in dunks, and I remember the Arena exploded
Oh raccattack. We're here lights camera action [wall] down the Middle behind the back
[no] gives it up the blood cell into the lane leans [in] left hand scoop. God
Here's a loan for wallet down
It was crazy [to] leader no we're doing who is good idea playing and having fun fun side of the lane pulls off your people
I don't think people really knew what to make of Kentucky early on
[there] were a lot of people who I think we're rooting for them to lose frankly that
This isn't the way college basketball is supposed to work. I was the important
I
Got in his face IV she handles like a hit the head. He was like this why we're here
[just] [follow] you he's right here, and there's a baby face it somebody I did a great bond with somebody I called my brother
Nightly basis is some type of sacrifice
[know] one night might have been here is one night on a binge on one night mother mother and we were okay
At the end of the day all [we] wanted to do to me [you]
[would] think there would be some sort of jealousy oh no?
But they had to believe in each other and they had to believe that
We as a staff we have your back
This is going to work for you. The ultimate goes with Magic Cherish it
That's all we wanted to do is [we'll] gamma [gone]. So what we did all season anything pay attention now. We're all serious
It's all about business from all 40 minutes of basketball will enjoy an after
execution wins in this term
29 now for Bledsoe 8 for 8 from three-Point range remember that I promise that'll do
number one [seed], Kentucky Wildcat
these sexual most [lights] on
You know you had Cornell
Ivy league and here you got these one-and-done kids all they don't care about school volleyball and it made the team mad and that week
Was actually a really interesting week in Kentucky because the national media used that as a chance to give a referendum about
Kentucky and about one and done
They're writing some of the nastiest articles about lead you guys you can't believe we're out of country, but it's nasty nasty
I'm talking to Boston all over the place. They don't want this team to win
I don't know what their deal. Is they drank the hater-aide, but you know what all I'm worried about is us
[Cornell's] too small to retain fit in that's all I kept in a lot of spelling me
this is basketball, [so]
Have a baby
As it's turned into the beatdown
Nasa head, oh
Kentucky impressively three straight game three consuming victories for the number one seed in the youth
And a little too, Morgantown today, we're we're good enough to be number one. We'll have a chance to prove it uh
West Virginia
one of those nights
We had one glaring flaw
Shooting and we just hoped we would not hit a game in the NCAa tournament. We couldn't make a shot
for three
We missed 20 straight trees, but we'll try another three
goes to the final four
Saddest locker worst worst and now they took the one game
one [bad] game they couldn't stop crying it never crossed their minds that they would lose [that] game and
When they did you know I've never seen guys like that since no one even if someone wins a national championship
They have more than 35 minutes
These just one of those games in the whole united States
but I want to tell you you know you came forward as it is no, I
want you to accept
That things that weren't on cross this year especially
Till this day we talked about their game and everything we could have done differently
Six years later in the NBA you know we all have a you know own personal success to this day. We still talk about
Talking to coach cows got no [brain] [and] everybody
Projecting them would be coming out of high school going into college, so he can't go no hiding number one
And he's gonna be honest with you if you got a chance to leave until you
He's never gonna type to hold any money go [for] it
You know when people say well you have to have a kid for years [now]. You don't know
you have to be about them, but
Changed how I thought about college and coaching and all those things and playing young guys
[it] changed a lot of things
it was the beginnings of
All right, look if you're doing right by these kids and they have opportunities to be in a lottery [b]
Draft, you gotta let me go our jobs to help these kids get jobs
History is made [V] kentucky player drafted in the first round
This is I'd like to say it's the biggest day in the history of Kentucky's program. It could have said in college basketball
Some block their minds because they didn't want kids to leave so they care less
We didn't win a national title about uh you know all that stuff
But the people that looked at it with an open mind said. [oh] goodness. What just happened
What happened? Are you kidding me you say well? What's the big deal in leaving?
one year of four well it could mean as much as
150 million Dollars, that's what to me
How about if that family was in generational Poverty?
generational
stops right there
The whole direction of that entire family is going this way now
Could you imagine my teams if guys stayed three and four years like the old days could you imagine these guys I?
Don't think every kid should leave after a year, and they're not already some kids leave anyway
That's their [choice] if they [choose] to go we're going [to] support. Yeah, but they weren't adhere for us to see them isn't about you
It's about them. It's not about me. It's about them. If I do right by them
They will take care of me personally, and they'll take care of this program
They've proven that to be true some would say out the worst
But if it were their child they would say, that's the best
[horn] and Select Anthony Davis
Michael Kidd-Gilchrist Nerlens Noel Julius Randle Karl-Anthony Towns
the University of Kentucky